hello my name is reto Meier welcome to
this week in Android development on
Monday September 9 2013 last week anchor
Nick put the unique anglo-australian
spin on this week in Android development
while I was putting a unique spin on my
toasted marshmallows my absence didn't
slow down the team though with the
release of new dev bites for animating
map markers effective efficient
prefetching understanding the patch
field audio architecture and
implementing card flip animations the
Google Play game services team were also
hard at work with another episode of
game on covering how to best support
game controllers for your android games
this week Android design in action will
be walking you through some of the most
common UX issues we encounter and i'll
be presenting the next episode of my
efficient data transfers devbytes
uncovering how to batch and bundle your
transfers using sync adapters not to be
outdone Daniel is back with another dev
by describing how to perform a listview
cell insertion animations new in
documentation last week was this guide
to getting started with the Android
testing framework and if you're in the
UK the latest update of BBC's iPlayer
lets you download your favorite TV shows
to enjoy when you're on the tube that's
all for this week in Android development
be sure to check out this week's dev
bites I'm ready Maya and I saw two
shooting stars last night I wished on
them but they were only satellites